there is a major major anti-vaxxer panic
over a total misunderstanding of a
vaccination situation I'm going to tell
you the story of Rebecca bread al who's
a Michigan mom previously Rebecca was
sent to jail for refusing to comply with
a court order that mandated her
nine-year-old son be vaccinated now you
might hear that and say a government a
court is mandating vaccinations for kids
well not exactly Rebecca used to have
primary custody of her son she was
released last week she was expecting to
be reunited with her son but not so fast
she has now lost primary custody which
will be split 50/50 with the son's
father
during this period the son also received
four immunizations and is now completely
up to date with vaccinations the mother
Rebecca Brett ow did not want her son
vaccinated the father did want her son
vaccinated anti-vaxxers are going nuts
saying the government cannot mandate
vaccinations the government is not
mandated vaccination Rebecca
agreed as part of a court custody
hearing to have the child vaccinated in
deference to the wishes of the father
she agreed to that as part of a custody
hearing she has not done that and thus
was held in contempt of court the fact
that it is vaccinations is secondary the
issue is she agreed to this in front of
a court as part of a custody hearing and
she has now said after agreeing to the
vaccinations that she doesn't want them
because of her religious beliefs
she's never detailed her religious
beliefs that I was able to find and who
knows if that's just something she's
saying to try to prevent the
vaccinations but she has not been jailed
for not vaccinating her kid specifically
the kid is not being given partial
custody to the father because she has
not vaccinated specifically it's because
she violated the custody agreement that
she agreed to in front of a court and
she has
into contempt of court by ignoring that
and the anti-vaxxers are going
absolutely and totally crazy about this
now to go back for a second to the
religious exemptions thing most states
actually still have religious exemptions
for vaccinations but it is not for any
purpose it is specifically if you want
your kids in public schools the
anti-vaxxers like to say government
mandates that kids get vaccines well no
no it's that government-run schools
public schools require vaccinations and
if you want your kid to go to those
schools which is by no means a necessity
then the kids need to be mat vaccinated
only California Mississippi and West
Virginia have removed exemptions from
school vaccinations for religious
purposes if you want your kids in those
schools then yes you are going to need
to comply and vaccinate them but you are
not obligated to do that I actually just
witnessed recently I was at a little
kind of fall gathering with some friends
and there were two people I know that
work in the medical field doing research
that's not directly related to
vaccination but it's kind of close and
an anti-vaxxer mom was there with full
indignation telling them they need to
look into the science more because she
knows the truth and they don't and it's
it's sort of it's an appeal to Authority
fallacy to say the people working in the
medical field are right merely because
they work in the medical field but the
idea that any random stay-at-home mom
who's homeschooling her kids to avoid
vaccinations knows more than people
actually working in the medical field
that I take issue with